hello everyone and welcome back to the
event it is the ftx crypto cup it is the
final round and it is the match that
will decide the winner now of the entire
event this is the second game of the
match pregnant versus magnus cross and
first game ended in a very fighting draw
and the second game is is just a
masterpiece by both players uh so let's
dive straight into it without wasting
any time there is uh there is so much to
cover and to enjoy uh prague has the
white pieces and he opens with d4 we
have knight to f6 by magnus c for e6
knight to f3 now not uh offering magnus
to go for the nimzo indian uh so going
for sort of a yeah anti-nimso variation
and now d5 by magnus we have knights to
c3 and bishop to b4 now transposing into
the aragos in defense we have queen to a
for check knights to c6 and now pawn to
e3 we have castles and queen to c queen
back to c2 and this is the most standard
uh variation that you can find in the
aragosan defense this is the election
variation of dragozin of the queensland
of the queen's gambit declined uh and
usually here rook to e8 is played the
characters on c4 is played b6 is played
but magnus plays a move that has only
been played once and has been played by
an incredibly strong player
in the candidates tournament that this
year in the game uh dingle iron versus
fabiana corona fabi played knight to a5
and this is the move that magnus plays
sort of test testing if um prague was
following the candidates and if prague
did any work on this variation and as
this was a classical game no doubt that
magnus knows quite a lot about this so
in the game uh dingler versus fabiano
corona ding played c5 and that game
ended in a draw and c5 is indeed the
most precise way to counter this weird
knight to the a5 move but probably
played c captures on the e5 and as this
is incredibly well analyzed this already
brings the game to to total equality
black can be very very happy with his
position now so it is now already as of
move eight that we have a completely new
game which is not surprising uh uh
knight to a5 only being played wise once
and as being continued in the strongest
way possible that this is now new
territory so he captures d5 by magnus
and bishop to d3 now putting pressure on
h7 and now c5 magnus strikes in the
center d captures on c5 by prague and
now knight back to c6 now of course the
bishop will recapture so you don't have
to worry about that bishop to d2
unpinning the knight and now bishop
captures on c5 we have knights to e2
prague could also just castle but then
maybe bishop to g4 is annoying so he
first starts with knights to e2 for the
tricky uh queen captures on c5 but
magnus says i can be tricky myself and
he plays knight to b4 now if prague
captures the bishop of course magnus
captures the light core bishop and also
delivers this beautiful royal fork and
off goes the queen so after knight b4 we
have queen to b1 by prague and now
magnus eliminates the bishop captures
captures and plays knight to e4 now puts
pressure on the uh dark square bishop
here on d2 uh so knight f to d4 first
and here magnus plays pawn to a5 and
this is now uh sort of a
there at the prague magnus is saying
okay if you castle king side i can shift
my rook into the attack play queen to h4
also the knight might help also the
bishop is coming
are you ready to defend this position
against me and prague believes in
castles here is in fact the best move
for for white but prague plays rook to
c1 puts pressure on this bishop which
could be very very dangerous but now
magnus just plays b6 shows that now he
has no more intentions of shifting the
rook
into the attack but now if prague
castles now magnus can play bishop to a6
and it's game over there's no defending
here uh for example queen c2 i just
bishop captures on d4 removing the
defender of the knight on e2 and of
course if you capture then you lose the
knight if you capture with the knight
you lose the exchange as bishop captures
on f1 grabs the rook and that's it let's
say rook captures roxy8
and
magnus would be completely winning here
so prague has to decide how to play here
and it's a pretty bad position so bishop
to c3 and now magnus plays bishop to a6
we have queen back to d1 and now rook
the c8
and what can what can proc play well uh
there really aren't all that many great
moves uh prague decides the castle and
now magnus just plays bishop captures on
d4 sort of being the whole point uh
because now bishop captures on d4 which
is the move you want to play a loses
material just through captures and again
you have this problem of queen captures
losing the knight and knight captures uh
losing the exchange or rather the rook
on f1 so instead after bishop captures
prague has to play eight captures uh uh
e captures on d4 but now queen to f6 by
magnus
i just putting more pressure on that
king side now again this is impossible
because the the f2 pawn would hang
and uh what do you play here probably
best is bishop d2 offering a rook trade
and then well everything just gets
traded off but this
also means that magnus would win upon
knight captures queen captures bishop
captures queen captures and now queen
captures on d4 wins magnus a clean pawn
he has a beautiful pass deep on and
prague would have to defend for the rest
of the game but prague wants to hang on
to everything and he plays f3 and this
is where the game really explodes now
magnus plays knight characters in c3 b
captures now completely messing up
frog's pawn structure and now the c3
point is a backward spawn and magnus has
a very clear way of how to win this and
this is not a winning position for black
and magnus just shows how quickly he can
spot uh the the winning variation he
plays queen e7 now putting pressure on
the knight uh so you can't really move
it otherwise bishop captures on f1 so
rook to e1 only move or maybe rook to f2
would be even better but uh you know who
would think of that so rook to e1 and
now queen to e3 with check putting
another attacker to the c3 pawn king to
h1 and now rook f the e8 just
threatening to win the material on the
spot and this basically forces prague to
offer a queen trade so nice to g3 and
the magnus trades off everything rook
captures queen captures a rook captures
rook captures and now you still can't
win material because rook 38 would be
checkmate so magnus plays g6 and now how
is prague to defend this his c3 pawn is
hanging and he plays rook to c1 which is
a
an ingenious way of defending this
position even though his position is
completely lost uh but again magnus
shows just what uh what a strong player
he is here um
uh prague's idea behind rook to c1 is
that if magnus goes for b5 and b4 which
seems to be winning at the spot uh he
has 92 and after b4 now attacking c3 and
the knight hanging on e2 he can just
play c captures on b4 it doesn't matter
if the knight is saying if you capture
the knight of course he would capture
the rook so here your best idea would be
just the trade and after pawn captures
you have this end game with equal
material where prague will definitely
not lose this uh but magnus shows just
how precise he is he plays rook to c4
now he wants to play rook a4 put the
bishop on c for win the a2 pawn or
rather even put pressure on the c3 pawn
and then uh even if prague is able to
defend this and he is just slowly bring
his king into the game and that that's
it so here at knights 32 proc sets up a
defense uh this is the only way to play
it rook to a for rook to c2 defending
the pawn and now if bishop c4 uh knights
to c1 was prague's idea just defending
this pawn here and then magnus would
slowly but surely start getting his king
into the game but uh interestingly
magnus goes for rook to a3 knights to c1
and now
he goes for bishop to b5 uh instead of
bishop to c4 which is very very
interesting uh it's sort of like he
abandoned his entire
endgame
knowledge
and just goes for the for the quick win
he wants to play bishop c4 kick away the
rook win the c3 pawn and claim that the
position will be winning for him uh and
okay rook king to g1 and now bishop to
a4 bishop the c4 still the more precise
idea then you start bringing the king
into the game uh but here magnus rushes
things with bishop to a4 goes after the
rook now comes rook to b2 attacking the
b6 spawn and the magnus trades rook
captures and now knights the e2
uh as the the knight is hanging so
knight a2 attacks the rook and now we
have rook to c4 by magnus
also rook the c2 can be played and for
example captures capture so now he would
have to prove that the bishop against
knight end game is winning with magnus
being up upon having 2-2 against one on
the queen side it wouldn't be easy
defending this but probably uh naprox
can hold this so magnus goes rook to c4
instead uh his idea being that if prop
captures he can play bishop to d1
eliminate the knight and then win the d4
pawn and create a past d-pawn and this
is exactly what happens in the game rook
captures on b6 bishop to d1 and now
prague plays king to f1 the most precise
way to defend forcing the trade bishop
captures king captures rogue characters
on d4 and now uh not rook to b5 um
which wouldn't be all that impressive if
rook to b5 than just a4 and magnus
is defending everything but instead he
goes king to f2 which is even more
impressive uh but but not as precise as
rook to b5 uh now magnus plays rook to
d2 with check here rook to a4 is the
much needed move putting pressure on the
a2 pawn but magnus goes for rook to d to
check instead and now we have kink the
g3 and now uh magnus plays rook to
now magnus plays pawn to a4 because here
if you go for rook captures on a2 then
rook to d6 puts pressure on this pawn
and now of course if rook to d2 then
prague can just shift the attention to
the a pawn so you will win one of them
and then of course it's a very well
known drawn variation uh so a4 by magnus
now comes a3 by prague and the rook to
d3 putting pressure on the a3 pawn and
now rook to b5 prague playing a
brilliant brilliant end game here king
to g7 and now rook to b4 we have rook
captures on a3 now comes rook to d4
attacking the d5 pawn king to f6 and
rook captures on d5 and now magnus does
have the outside pass pawn
but can he win this we have rook to c3
rook to a5 prague gets his rook behind
the pass pawn there was no way to avoid
this and now
pawn to a3 here
uh the the better move was rook to c for
preventing prague from uh entering the
game with king to f4 uh but both of them
are now a very very long time they are
both below the one minute mark uh here
we have this pawn to eighth remove this
is how magnus defends the pawn and now
proc plays king to f4 we have kink the
e6 by magnus pawn to h4 now we have f6
uh
maybe king to d6 was better but again
very very low on time so we're not going
to go into details king the e4 and now
h5 by magnus we have kinked the d4
forcing the rook away rook b3 and king
to c4 this is how prague gets all the
way to the a3 pawn rook to b2 magnus
goes after the g2 pawn now and now
prague shows that he can play the end
game as well as magnus rook captures uh
on a3
rook captures on g2 and now king to d3
basically the only move that doesn't
lose for prague and he shows y here we
have g5 by magnus captures captures and
now king the e3 and there is no way to
actually hold this here you can see that
controls all of all of these squares and
now his plan is just to check uh check
magnus's king along the a file and there
is no way to stop this h4 by magnus rook
the a6 check now magnus will hide behind
his g pawn rook to a5 checking the g6
rook to a6 check king to h5 but now just
to rook to a8 and prague will continue
the checking uh checking spree so here
rook to b2
and now just rook to h8 which came to g6
and now while you could continue
checking uh prague just shows how he can
very uh
easily draw this pawn to f4 uh and if
you capture of course then king captures
there's no winning this the black king
is too far away from the past pawn so
after h3 uh f captures and g5 was played
king captures and king to f3 now pawn to
h2 and now just king to g3 and on the
next move the king will capture the pawn
if the rook checks the king
and if you don't then rook captures on
h1 so here magnus just played rook to a2
and after rook captures an h2 rook
captures and king captures it was in
this position that prague and magnus
drew the game or rather the game is a
draw by insufficient material so you can
see how one imprecision frog made me
made magnus completely exploited and
then he completely messed it up he
rushed it in a position that he probably
knows how to play uh
well one would say in his sleep uh as he
found the the cleanest way to win this
the rook the c4 solution but then when
it was time to
uh just uh you know uh put the bishop on
c4 and uh completely paralyzed prague
after knight to c1 there are no moves
for prague as everything you know the if
you move the
uh the night that the a2 pawn falls then
you lose the game and then the point was
to just start bringing the king into the
game improve the position as much as
possible and then decide on how you are
going to or rather where you're going to
make the breakthrough so very very
interesting turn of events uh after two
games the situation is a draw uh prague
managed to escape and now it's becoming
uh incredibly intense what will happen
we'll probably get a win in the rapid
section and win the entire event uh well
we'll just have to wait and see
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it really like i said a
masterpiece by both of them but at some
point magnus should have done what he
does best you know just squeeze that
water from stone
but prague shows that he is also a
brilliant endgame player himself uh so i
really once again hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank attila
uh brian enriquez uh
krishna kumar uh lucian grozov and
akshay pandit for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the ftx
crypto cup uh until it finishes uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day